I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense I got picked last on a dodgeball
team one time in school and third grade
and I was just like never again am i how
you're like six foot you're probably 5
10 minutes I was tall yeah I was like 6
foot then and I was a pretty decent
athlete I was like I remember this I
don't know if you know story but I had
there was they took us out and recess
and had a the class do dodgeball right
and we're gonna split the half the class
into and the teacher picked like two
guys to pick pick the kids yeah two
copies
yep and they're picking one by one the
boys in the class right so they picked
all the guys first and I'm thinking I'm
gonna be when the first people picked in
my mind because I was a pretty good
athlete at this time all the boys get
picked and then they start picking the
girls oh my god and I'm standing I'm
like what the hell is going on like I'm
a good athlete right and so they stick
all the guys then they pick one by one
all the girls
I liked an 11 yeah yeah 10 11 maybe oh
my gosh 9 10 11 somewhere on there maybe
it's cuz girls mature quicker I don't I
don't know I was a tallest kid in class
I was like I thought I was a good
athlete whatever then they picked all
the girls one by one and then there's me
the last one and then even picked me I
was just by default on that next
person's team and for whatever reason
then something snapped inside of me I
was like mother efforts like yeah first
off I just felt like taking advantage of
I felt abused my house my old life was
like this feeling of abuse and being
taken advantage of because I was sexual
abuse mm that's kind of the pattern that
I've found that I have to really like be
mindful of like okay if I feel like
someone's taking an advantage of me it's
okay like I don't have to react like
they're sexually abusing theirs right I
mean it's okay but that's kind of the
story in the pattern that I've that have
been in and so something snapped and I
was just like I'm gonna destroy everyone
in this dodgeball and I was just like
catch everything the throwing any kids
face is awesome and I was just like
never again will anyone choose me last
and kind of like you or I it's like I
had this goal in my mind and I was just
like I'm after class or whatever was
done 3 o'clock every day I was at the
gym till 10 o'clock every night playing
basketball
playing soccer playing football it
working out whatever I could do I was
playing a sport until I had to go home
because it was this deep dark like
desire to be something more than picked
last and I was like I'm gonna prove
every one kid wrong was ever made fun of
me who's ever bullied me picked on me
abused me I was like everyone's gonna be
wrong and that was the driving force to
me you know achieving every that I did
in athletics until I hit 30 I realized
like my whole life I've been doing
things to prove everyone wrong and I
think it's the second most powerful fuel
in the world the most powerful is
lifting others up and being of service
and coming from a place of inspiration
rather than meaning to look good be
right right and be the best mm-hmm
it'll get you far but it left me very
unfelt you go
I needed the win I needed to be right at
all costs and I was a horrible loser
horrible loser like no one could be
around me because I was just angry and
moody and when I realized like wow I've
been doing it all wrong it's gotten me
far it helped me make a lot of money and
chief athletic success but it's like why
do I still feel lonely inside and sad
especially after I achieved my biggest
year goals of 10 20 year goals I'm the
most lonely why so I think these moments
of my life I really reflect and I start
to ask myself why am i this way why do I
feel this way after a situation after
I'm succeeding after I'm failing after a
breakup whatever it is why that's right
and I'm that's what my biggest lessons
come because if so many people blame on
the girl right they're like oh they this
they that we are responsible for
everything a hundred feet away but I've
learned it and when I take full
responsibility for everything my parents
why the sexual abuse losses the winds
the breakups what are the good the bad
when I take ownership for it all even if
I didn't actually do it but if I take
responsibility I feel so much peace but
I don't have anyone else to blame mm-hmm
I just accept it I don't say it's okay
yeah that these things happen but I say
okay it's happened and I've accepted it
what can I learn from this where's the
good in this and how can I move forward
and that's what brings me a lot of peace
yeah
[Music]